votre réputation de séducteur et donc de
l'ut 1h de secrétaires et est allée
jusqu'aux oreilles des deschiens n ai
pas parlé jusqu'à moi et que moi aldo
mais pourquoi vous avez vous fait de
assad raid pour faire plus vrai choix
c'est françois morel t a été improvisée
ça pendant pendant la prise
oui pour vous faire plaisir alors tout
traduit en portugais tout joliment crazy
livres qui sont traduit en portugais oui
est ce que vous êtes et ce que vous avez
lu je soares jean d'ormesson
non j'avais pas lu j'ai vu maintenant en
français un français un livre d'ailleurs
jeu superbe avec un humour on va parler
de talent mais c'est le parti dénommé
c'est pour rendre de jean d'ormesson
baudet c'est ce que vraiment il est
connu et ce qu'il est lui au brésil
bon il a pas seulement il est connu
comme il a des amis il est de l'académie
brésilienne de l'être oui oui oui vous
étiez je crois que je vous demande
pardon je crois que j'ai succédé à
malraux oui c'était un huitième mort
d'ailleurs à laquelle il concède
succéder à jules romains et l'homme est
là et je crois qu'à l'académie j'ai
chanté une petite chanson en brésilien
oui que je peux vous chantez réussi
chansons de carnaval
oui un maillot pierre mailhot pierre
d'achoppement te promènes en short et
bizarre je sais pas si vous savez et je
ne sais pas si vous savez que de malraux
avec beaucoup d'amis brésilien oui mais
chantait aussi ça marrant non non et que
ça veut dire ça veut dire c'est du
chansons du carnaval travailler à maman
maman j'ai envie le tt
non on y donne la sucette sinon je vais
pleurer dans la soupe est assassin et
c'est ça que monsieur d'ormesson chanter
au brésil
voilà un ça je ne sais pas si on lui a
donné une sucette mais je vais me
retirer phone aussi s'était donné un
coup de main d'oeuvre jamais à 12 r 25
26 6 0 6 0
enfin ça ne répond plus